hello I'm mark Catan chick the CTO
involved analytics today I will be
talking about life doesn't have to be
heart wherein we use our data model or
software to easily handle multivariate
data extract insights and to handle
missing data and correlated data all the
things are associated with the real
world
topic of the day I should have titled it
as I titled his life doesn't have to be
hard the reality is as data science
doesn't have to be hard so I probably
should have made that a little more
clear anyhow one of the things that
happen in my history is I I started
start off working in in industry and
discovered that as those in that world
know they're great at collecting data
they're great at doing and records
retention but getting the extracting the
inside out of multivariate data
efficiently is is difficult it's
intrinsically hard so what we'll see
today is something that has had a close
to 20 year gestation to get to get to
this point the basically the idea is
that let the data speak for itself let
the you know handle real world data real
world data with correlated variables
lots of variables
missing records missing data within
records you've just got to be able to
roll through that I mean if you do if
you look at a lot of the analysis tools
you have to go through and form a
perfectly numerical matrix you've got to
do a lot of pre-processing to get
something that's suitable for the
algorithms which means every single path
you chase down you're building more and
more different data sets so with that
introduction I'll I'll talk about the
the tool here is data modeler it's great
trying to get this screen matching
properly
yeah all right good enough
and so data modeler started off as a as
a function package so we have roughly
450 functions that are built and data
modeler these are accessible for the
power users they're exposed their
excruciating ly well documented but the
problem is you you go out and you know
so okay this is strictly for Mathematica
community users hype you know you have
to be able to hit shift in or and and
know what you're doing
recognizing that that was an issue
started working at building a GUI and
what we have here is just basically you
throw the data in and the assumption is
couple that you have you're within a
flat you can create a flat file database
with a header row data Excel CVS
whatever comes into Mathematica and at
that point the computer the algorithms
have to support the user you don't
support the algorithm and the
presumption that we're going to do is
that data lives even though we have lots
and lots of variables that would
actually what we're the things that we
care about it a relatively small subset
of variables so we're going to try to
identify the key variables try to build
models against them extract insights
about relationships those aspects and
eventually start pulling out models that
we might deploy and furthermore because
of the path that we're following we're
able to build trust able models so the
the first example here help pre-loaded
the presumption is that I'm going to
pick a target variable so this is this
is a training problem prediction
predictive analytics would be another
word for it pick a target and I'm going
to go figure out what's happening step
one is to get the the Zen of your data
the Zen is it's important because it
sort of tells you what you want to do in
this case this is the distillation
column from a chemical plant we have
lots of correlated variables blue is is
highly positive correlated red the
darker the red it's negatively
correlated I mean and this is sort of a
real-world situation one of the neat
tools and again all these things are
available in the exposed functions for
the power user to build custom workflows
is to look at the data sets and say you
know is it you know what's the
distribution look like is it quantized
do I have something that's on a log
function where I wanted might maybe do
some some scaling on that is it possibly
quantized how complete is it you know
plotting the data these these sorts of
things I think this one this one's sort
of interesting in that we detected that
a couple of the variables were quantized
and looked like they you know so the
display automatically shifts to be able
to reveal that information and more
accurately display results I mean I
think this is you know eight thousand
data points something roughly in that
ballpark in this case this is a purely
numeric matrix that we have we have all
good stuff but I wanted to use this
example because I ran a bunch of
modeling runs to get to get to the in
here what we're doing in the model
search is we're looking at we're
generating random models just
nothing was using the variables at hand
building models and then from those
rewarding those that are both simple and
accurate soar rewarding two things and
we're doing an evolutionary process and
overtime unnecessary variables get
pushed out unnecessary complexity gets
pushed out model accuracy increases but
what we're doing is we have a population
of models and these are there may be a
little small that's what you see is
we're we're evolving algebraic
expressions so so rather than assuming
that the world's a second-order
polynomial with no cross terms we're
letting the data decide what's an
appropriate model now the thing is
because of the stochastic nature of this
we have lots of different paths to
success with lots of different models
which which can come to the fore and be
you know approximately equal so if I
move to the analyze tab and shift to on
this case
little twitchy there we go don't double
hit so if we if we shift to this view
and this is a view of all the models
which were created in these 16
five-minute model searches her three
minute model searches what we see is
sort of lots of different structures now
from the point of view of deploying
something they're all roughly equal I
mean they're they're reasonably accurate
and in this case extremely accurate you
know better than 98% r-squared and and
reasonably simple you know so we're
going to prefer if we will a model like
this which is fairly compact has a
handful of variables as opposed to
something I'm over the tooltip limit you
know this model out here is just you
know does it give us a more attained in
terms of accuracy but it adds a lot of
complexity so we don't like that so I'm
gonna move over we can I've loaded in
you know I've done a couple modeling
rounds and so now I've loaded in the the
round of three contenders which have
archived off onto disk it's what you
what you do during the model searches is
you're looking for say what variables
are coming to the fore so
so my initial my initial exploration got
me lots and lots and lots of decent
models I'm gonna choose I'm going to
choose a subset oh I'm gonna choose a
subset that are that are interesting
okay evidently the loaded the wrong data
set in or didn't load it in there we go
all right so now I've got now I've got a
bunch of models that I've loaded and
these you know sort of you know 400 plus
models and I want to say what you know
what does this mean well first I'm gonna
say you know how many how many variables
are required to get to something decent
so this this particular chart of this is
the distribution of the number of
variables in the developed models but of
the models with three variables I have
different paths of success so so reflux
flow temperature tray one vapor flow
seemed to have been pretty popular I got
pretty good models out of out of the
deal if I go to four I get more
variables but I've also got different
paths different combinations of
variables so this is important to to to
look at the possibilities of your
variable selection because I might have
in a real world problem
I would prefer controllable variables
over over things they're simply
measurements so if I'm doing social
science type thing you know if I've got
a knob I can tweak to to control things
I'd rather use that have that knob in my
models rather than something like
latitude you know where it's yes there's
a correlation but it's not a
controllable correlation I can go
through and you know based upon this
inside I can look at at which variables
have come to the fore and I'm folk now
here I'm focused in on you know a
handful have really sort of popped up
and of a you know I can start focusing
down I'm gonna slowly iterate down and
and see which ones really count I can
look at variable combinations and what a
what I've done here just in the interest
of time I've picked out a few models
and so eventually we went through and I
decided I wanted to really had three
variables gonna beam off these three
variables I do some more modeling and
these models are you know so I've got
close to the 200 models they're you know
they're varied
they're all different they're all unique
structures let's take a look at what you
know how they perform so if I look at an
individual model there's one and and I
look at its prediction plot which is a
you know error versus you know observe
versus reality you know I I get a
distribution sort of like this where you
know so we shifted because we had so
many data points we automatically
shifted to a density plot to show where
the thing was because otherwise you just
have this sort of all these blue dots
lined up and you don't have an idea that
you know really you're fitting the
majority of the data pretty well you
know if I shift to a different model may
I get a slightly different result so you
know which you know what do I do in this
circumstance you know how do I pick the
model and and remember we're we're
dealing with real world data so it's got
noise in it I'm not sure I measured
every variable there actually mattered
well one solution is to use an ensemble
so an ensemble is fairly simple it's
just I'm going to take all those models
that I defined as sort of good enough in
being both simple and accurate and I'm
going to choose a diverse set of those
and this supermodel
has a special property now so it's going
to predict well where there's data
because otherwise it wouldn't be a good
model
but because we've explicitly chosen them
for their diversity if we ask that model
to go into a new region of parameter
space or the underlying system changes
then we're going to get a heads up that
that this thing should not be trusted
yeah you know I've got a prediction for
you now the problem with the model is
it's it's a big pile of trust me with
these supermodels you've you've got a
prediction that generally behaves pretty
well in extrapolation but also you've
you've got the warning that you should
proceed cautiously this particular
dataset
[Music]
okay okay
have the same display up so so here so
I'm going to load in I don't want to I'm
gonna jump to load in a couple
individual models rather than population
so I've let's take a look good I'm gonna
what I want to do I'm gonna do my
individual models and I want to see how
they perform against two data sets so
I've got a training data set and an a
test data set now my contention
personally is that I prefer to have my
models be the most informed that I can
make I want it then that be exposed to
all of the data I'm going to rely on on
this ensemble nature to give me the best
the best data
[Music]
if however I look at my my two bottles
human samples well if I look at my
prediction plot this particular data set
was chosen to test extrapolation so you
see that the the one model you know fits
hurt or well but then we start we're
missing the middle the middle data and
and we've got the the extremes that
haven't been covered those are you know
so that informations there but if we go
to a Ensemble and we look at the
prediction plot we're going to look at a
response plot DoubleClick's
all right so that the response plot
Explorer here is is looking at the the
data now to see you know we've got a lot
of constitute these if you can see these
little gray lines in here and that's
sort of the constituent models and so
we're plotting the envelope of this so
the zone of uncertainty you know the
reality is that we haven't covered I
mean this is a real-world plant it's not
covering the entire data space he's got
you know you have operating conditions
that are are coupled even though there's
no nominally independent so if we were
to increase the vapor flow but not
increase anything else we have a
prediction but we have an uncertainty
around that prediction you know on the
same same deal for both of them if we
come to the if we sort by the observed
values and we go to we go to the extreme
all right so so the okay so we have you
know some uncertainty but what we see is
that the the you know our test set had
had been testing in the you know asking
to extrapolate further we get a lot more
uncertainty in those at those data
records now just as a as a nicety here
if i want to deploy this model i've i've
got a couple different mechanism but i
might want to hand it off to somebody
else to look at it i can export this
explorer and and now I have a CDF that
doesn't require either our data model or
software just or Mathematica it means
just strictly runs in the CDF player so
you can hand somebody a model they can
play the what-if since and see some of
the responses okay I'm gonna run out of
time so I want to jump quickly to a
slightly different project because this
is something I think this is sort of
neat so that one of the issues comes up
of course is you get a lot of real-world
data sets have binary trinary sort of
low order categoricals true/false
survive dead in the case so I just the
Titanic survivals data if we go pop into
our our data exploration we have we see
we have missing data we also see our
data summary table that we've got our
you know categorical inputs so you
either either live or you die but we're
able to model with that now similarly
you know the display plots are gonna
automatically shift so you're not
connecting the dots between this goods
there's there is no middle ground
between living and dying well maybe some
states but you know so we've got that
we've got that sort of mapping going on
if we go to
analyzing the models
I can look at that and we'll just pick a
a model to look at I don't have an
ensemble defined here you know I've got
you know not not very good models but
I've got you know plots that that
automatically shift depending upon the
nature of the output so that I can see
because otherwise otherwise in this case
we'd have a you know a lineup blue dots
to line up so we can see that we're
actually getting some some prediction
and I can shift that around even further
and go to something like mushroom
edibility where you
it's either poisonous or not poisonous
and here I've got a purely categorical
data set and I'm able to to do
regression and model against that now
and you know sort of choose the
threshold of how how many you know
what's what's low enough order
categorical it's a two variables three
variables five variables if I have more
than five and 95% of the data is is in
five variables well do I want to just
sort of ignore the stuff that's outliers
you know that's you know that's a you
know can be done and you still build
models around to what the availability
of information which which factors in
this case of mushroom edibility
do you really care about in in terms of
bet in your life that I'm hungry I'm in
the woods
Danny Danny's in the woods someplace and
he's hungry starving to death does he
feel lucky so that on that note I'm
sorry out of time so I'll open it up for
questions and and I think what's really
neat though is is the ability to just
sort of throw the data in and even
though it's missing data and now and now
categorical
we can still get some insight out in
terms of which variables are driving the
behavior I didn't talk about we can you
know look at data structures or their
ratios for example there that appear to
be in successful models is that
something that has meaning to us meta
variables so okay yes yes yes the the
the large user interface is I mean this
is 100% pure Mathematica the GUI that
you know the GUI is just a massive
dynamic module but each of the named
functions like univariate plot is in the
the function library
so there's correspondence that way
well there is like I could not so much I
mean everything you can go retrieve the
data and you can see what the functions
look like I can capture capture like
this uni very a plot and go to a report
and I could say move to report select it
and then move to the report and open the
report and what happens is my round
comments ok yes alright we got it a
little bug what oh I have to enable
dynamics ok so what I can do is I can as
I go through this just slides the stuff
into a standard Mathematica notebook so
that you can leave an audit trail
because one of the neat things about a
Mathematica notebook interface you've
got this sort of long audit trail of my
analysis and I can go back and repeat
things however when you're talking about
sort of this data analysis things so now
I've isolated down to which variables
now I want to pop back and go look drill
into just those variables what's there
what's there scatterplot looked like
what's there correlations look like so I
you know you sort of have this
interactive nature which is really hard
given the linear nature of a notebook
interface so you know the the concept of
having a documentation notebook that you
can slide stuff in tries to leave the
audit trail and the breadcrumbs you know
all the models are saved save to disk
you know within the within the folder
structure so yes Danny
yes yes it omits the data within the
model because one problems of the CDF is
that it can't go external right so so
this is so anybody that you know doesn't
have enterprise Mathematica is still
able to put something meaningful out
there so and of course the owner has to
every you know not is doesn't you know
now it has to be 100% native Mathematica
code for that okay yep ah the interface
the interface we would give credit to
Ariel Sepulveda who is he's got a home
in Puerto Rico but it doesn't have any
power or electricity or water at the
moment but I don't know that means three
years three years huh yeah I mean it was
really I mean it was a sort of a you
know very much an iterative process you
start to things you've got air ariel
comes from a Windows environment so has
no no sense of color so we so Teresa and
Katia were you know explicitly choosing
the colors to go to go across the tops
for the the different elements of the
workflow I mean so what we tried to do
is is sort of here are the tools and
then we tried in the GUI get it mapped
into the workflow that's that's
appropriate so that's you know it's want
to make it easy to do the right thing
and hard to do the wrong thing so okay
any other questions
right thank you it's a whirlwind tour
but tried to pack a lot in
[Applause]